das mag ich zwar aber jetzt auch nicht
so sehr
es gibt praktiken es gibt wirklich
taktiken wie die leute was die zuerst
machen wenn du zb das und das machen
solltest du dich um dies machen und dann
hast du gewonnen
ich habe auch gelesen wenn man zuerst
zuerst nehmen die meisten nicht schere
wenn man die finger in so weit
auseinander ziehen muss aber klar sein
dass so eine chance von lass mich
rechnen ein drittel
ja nee dann hast du eine chance von zwei
drittel
wenn wenn wenn zu ihm zu gewinnen hast
du ja gut ich weiß wie ich mich jetzt
schon frale das ist natürlich an die
rena style würdig was sagen aber naja
wer passt schon den astra kann sich
nicht nennen weil das ist jetzt ein
toter style to get together style das
will ich will immer den kommentaren
stehen kann kann sich schon darauf
vorbereiten nämlich zu beteiligen wie tg
sda das stahlseil komisch da oben ist
übrigens noch nicht wieder tag wo ich
nicht ob ich nicht lust einmal so kurz
das wort lu xun überhaupt ich weiß nicht
wo ich kann euch luke da immer mal so um
die ecke oder so was kann ich wenn ich
schon das wort her kommt es ihm so ein
nordlicht wort sind holstein setzt
gleich tot wenn du das noch weiter sinkt
wenngleich herauslaufen und voll der
miese pro band der ein skelett erblickt
und den rückweg antritt wir befinden uns
gar zum zweiten partie
wir haben würden wir noch und wir haben
uns noch gar nicht geschlagen oder doch
am anfang ja ich habe nicht nur ich hab
ich nur gekitzelt das war ein fehler
ja und ich wollte eigentlich zeigen aber
dann warst du im weg weil du wirst aus
politik und dann dachte ich du bist dann
zeigen macht man wenn man dem mann den
in dem man praktisch den einmal haben
einmal so rum schwingt so hätte sich
gerne irgendwie dass ihr sehen würde was
ihr macht einmal rum wie man es im
sportunterricht beim aufwärmen immer
noch einmal so umdrehen würde nicht so
wichtig für uns ich fell und rebell
richtete schnell verbaut apple abführen
weg ich bin dafür dass wir hier ein
bisschen in die höhle kurz rein gemacht
ist kommt es kommen sie kurz mit
ja du immer
nur ein feuerzeug jetzt und dann brauche
ich mir tnt und dann besprechen dass
eine luft oder war es das erst mal
wieder ein etwas
man muss sein mittlerweile auch wirklich
immerhin hast du übrigens ein thema oder
wollen wir erstmal eine höhle herrscht
immer ein thema doch kommen wir
schneiden erstes thema anwender vista
kompatibel schreiben dann und so laut
thema da habt ihr einfach ein gutes
thema krieg dann direkt mal als
vorschlag das ding ist nur ich hätte
jetzt so viele themen ab jetzt erst mal
kurz die spieler erst mal kurze weiter
wir müssen dem laser frau mit brille
play4free das thema das man nicht von
free thema übrigens jetzt grad tag das
ist sehr unsinn folgen jetzt eine hülle
gehen ob ich dann bauen wir erstmal an
am tageslicht und danach können wir dann
das thema anritzen wenn wir dann in der
höhe gehen wenn wir dann kann auch
nebenbei jetzt reden fällt mir gerade
dann machen wir es einfach einzunehmen
weil du ein thema das mir christian
geschickt hat von könnte so heißt ein
kanal ja chris leerzeichen tieren
oh oh mein gott und der liebe christi
christian ahlers beendet und soll er
geschrieben könnte es so weil ich
diesmal suchen dass sie auch bei mir
direkt weiterspielen kann
themen für ein let's play den kannst du
mal im netz play reden wie dich deine
mitschüler oder lehrer behandeln als
let's play hast du dann ihren status als
interessant weil man einfach so mal
darüber reden kann was eigentlich auch
ihr so denkt was so ein was wir so als
let's play aso als jetzt wäre
teleportiert was ihr denn vielleicht so
denkt was let's play dass wir irgendwie
ja was ich ja wirklich schrecklich finde
ist dass ländern importiert sich davon
aber wie soll ich anziehen bin aber so
anziehen
es ist neun achsen ein also was ich
schrecklich finde ist dass wir als
götter angesehen werden dass let's play
als köpfe angesehen werden wir kommen
auf den server oder auf den teamspeak
server
die hier gott der muss jetzt hier sofort
sogar dann finde ich gar nicht ich finde
wir sind leute wie man menschen wie
jeder andere auch und sollten auch so
behandelt werden weil das eben und das
kann man eigentlich auch darüber um bz
direkt zum thema zu kommen die
mitschüler oder lehrer und behandeln
weil wir jetzt will sie sind ganz
normale er wir sind ganz normale
menschen laden ja auch mehr oder weniger
schlechte schüler ich mein gutes wissen
bei mir also warum auch nicht die
meisten dass ich diese videos auf
youtube mache also bei mir ist es so es
wissen einige aber nicht alle es ist
also man kann es halt wirklich ab einem
bestimmten ab einer bestimmten zeit kann
man echt nicht mehr verbergen möchte ich
mal dahin
ich finde mich nicht dafür stehen aber
abgesagt hier ich mach das und das aber
das kommt einfach von selbst
ja ich möchte jetzt nicht sagen dass ich
mich dafür schämen dass ich videos mache
aber ich wollte halt das jetzt nicht
eine große glocke hängen ich bin ich so
ein typ der sagt youtube-videos
abonniert mich nein also ich möchte ich
trennen das ja auch eigentlich youtube
und real life ist für mich was komplett
anderes und ich rede auch mit meinen
freunden so jetzt nicht über ihn welche
youtube-videos oder let's player weil
die ist nicht gucken ich gucke es nicht
und ich mache halt einfach irgendwas
sinnvoll ist für mich zu tun
ich baue hier gerade den weg als doch
tage machen wir hier in der höhle keller
neben auch steine
wir gehen jetzt hier erstmal hochachtung
ein haus bauen heißt denn wie kraus
unter wasser aus aber mehr raus das
rathaus unter der erde aus nicht
überlegt mir bei weiße der takte er
schon wieder für kredite ja auch mal was
mir gerade eingefallen ist so bei der 50
folge oder bei der vierzigsten folge
einfach mal so rum gehen und schon zeigt
in einer folge was wir bisher schon also
gebaut haben
der vorher nachher vergleich für ihr ist
es damals weißt du noch damals in der
ersten woche als golden kräfte ach ja
das war noch die guten alten zeiten
aber wie soll wir wollten uns heute hier
so ziemlich direkt in die mitte bauen
damit die leute sich dann halt so
drumherum ansiedeln es wäre aber als
ding baust dich jetzt direkt über eine
höhle ist hier die höhle
ich hab keine ahnung ja ich gehe noch
ein bisschen nach hier so auf den klein
auf die kleine anhöhe also ein bisschen
kleinen überblick
achtet werden wir auch noch mehr und
sonst mal ein bisschen terraforming wird
erdige schaufel bis zum g nehmen geht
das auch weiter
doch wieder zum abschluss zu bringen
also an sich oder um die frage einfach
direkt zu beantworten ja ein bisschen
weiter ausgeholt also meine mitschüler
wandel mich na ja als relativ normal ist
es manchmal so dann kommt ja da einfach
spaß einmal wird dann gesagt also die
gucken meine videos jetzt nicht aktiv
aber ab und zu schauen das sollte dabei
ein
und dann kommen sie auch wenn ich
morgens in die schule kommen aber das ja
auch als er ins theater lässigen
schulter sein weil ich meine bei mir in
meiner schule kommen manchmal leute an
die das jetzt wissen einfach
herausgefunden haben wir das wird dann
so rum erzählt der und der der macht
diese videos auf youtube und dann bist
du das bei mir ist es nie etwas zu tun
gehabt haben mit dem ich lieber tagen
genau das will ich auch so
ich bin mit einem bei mir in der stufe
der heißt felix und sei nicht das nein
der heiz augen felix und ihm sein bruder
ihm sein bruder sein deutsch ist
schlecht es ist schlecht sein bruder
schaut meine videos aktiv und ich war
auch einmal bei einer party von felix
und da hat sein bruder damit nachher in
die kommentare auch irgendwie
geschrieben
hey auf der party von meinem bruder ist
eine stimme ja ganz schön den anus
gegangen und so weil meine stimme recht
ein bisschen kann sich dann und so und
der in seiner stufe da kennt mich so gut
wie jeder so von den leuten die jetzt
displays gucken also bei mir ist es so
in meiner stufe guckt niemand displays
die coop vielleicht alberto und solche
leute weil okay der schwarz weiß wann
witzmann spaß
erstmalig wird durch das war nur die aus
einer stufe die kennen mich halt und das
fand ich interessant wo er dann wirklich
zu mir hin kamen also nicht er sondern
jemand anderes hey willst du dich von
crafter masse videos und ich so ja warum
ja ich wollte nur sagen ich finde das
eigentlich voll cool und du hast da mein
respekt das war nicht ein echt cool wenn
dann wirklich so leute zu die rankommen
mein haus mein respekt für das was du
tust dann merkt man so ok das was du
machst es eigentlich ganz gut
also du machst du was richtig naja das
hat auch persönlich von leuten zuhören
und nicht nur über die kommentare das
ist natürlich dann auch mal ein
kommentar ist natürlich auch schön aber
persönlich ist natürlich mal interessant
ist
der games oder was ja auch dieses bild
geschenkt bekommen hat richtig gesehen
wie deine augen geleuchtet haben ach das
ist schön wenn solche alter ist jetzt
dein ernst ich hab mir grad alles schön
zugebaut und du bist jetzt ab das heißt
sich dann ernst wurde
ich wollte hier mein haus bauen hier
drauf ja denke ich hier ein bisschen
weiter weg zumindest also nicht dass wir
direkt anfordern nicht wieder so schmal
mich zwar aber jetzt auch nicht so sehr
kommen denn die bisherigen hast kannst
du da den dänen als keller aus wo
benutzen dann werde ich ja hier ein
bisschen ganzen haben aber nie alles ich
brauche das ja auch ich halte das ja
auch ab damit ich ein bisschen spielraum
so terraforming sicher habe ich trage
immer die oberste schicht ab weil dann
habe ich halt dann so während ich mir
überlege dass ich die minecraft mal
leiser stelle bevor er ein allgemeinen
fast gar nicht mehr an also noch ein
bisschen was man so prepaid oder so ja
das ding ist nur dass ich hier gewohnt
bin dass ich die stimme immer nachher
noch weiß immer zu laut oder stelle aber
ich bin ja jetzt immer noch ihr leben
aber jetzt eine die aufnahmen also deine
stimme und den minecraft das iphone kann
ich nicht getrennt über machen also wenn
das gras sorry dass dich jetzt
unterbrechen muss aber ich bin das erste
mal auf einem kanal vertreten so richtig
so echt
naja ich gerade einmal war schon immer
einmal mit ok es gibt andere person
musste schonach gott jetzt habe ich eine
nachricht von focus online bekommen die
paralympics in london da hat eine birgit
kober gold geholt im speerwurf
supermacht einmal kurz in einer blau ist
für birgit ober in die kommentare wieder
sternchen klatsch sternchen schreiben er
auf jeden fall auf jeden fall das kennen
sie ja schon so ein running gag hier
mehr oder weniger nicht schon aber
nächstes thema paralympics ich war ich
hab ich schon der dritten folge sind
weil sie wollen ja wir sind jetzt gerade
25 minuten aber wir können auf jeden
fall noch länger
wir können auf vier folgen erst mal so
machen würde ich sagen ja beides
erinnert gehen wir das hier so läuft
allerdings noch gar nichts geschafft
haben ja richtig richter verkalkuliert
und ich habe mir außerdem wurden packs
gemacht
des todes so blöd ich hasse den er so
dumm aber dann stärkt das paralympics 25
minuten dann lassen wir sie noch zappeln
und das thema paralympics damit nehme
ich ein paar persönliche anmerkung zu
machen was den an den paralympics nicht
zumal da schneiden wir dann gleich mal
annahmen
darin ist undercover die nächste sache
für nicht für flucht vor nächste to
cable show gesagt das folgen für die
nächste show für die nächste generation
die bande soll sich echt so einbringen
wie bei twitter mit dem hashtag oder so
cases letzten spiel aber schon so ein
bisschen einprägen
das ist kein to better das ist die
talkshow meine lieben freunde eben und
auch kein let's play tor sondern die
tiershow und auch wenn es jetzt in den
ersten vollständig ganz so durchdringen
spätestens wenn dann ab den ersten wenn
ersten vier pilot folgenden hier weg
sind oder die ersten 3 pilot vor je
nachdem wie ich ihnen heute noch machen
sobald in die gäste da sind werdet ihr
merken dass das halt doch ein bisschen
was anderes ist und wenn ihr zum
beispiel euren freunden erzählen hey
guck mal auf youtube da gucke ich das
und das ne da können einfach sagen guck
dir mal die tokio an
das ist recht klein das ist einfach mal
hier guckt euch kong kräfte an oder
guckt euch von den beiden genauso wie
doch gar nicht dass man guckt euch das
zu gerber von kontrast und die man da an
sondern guckt euch einfach die today
show das ist wie sein name und auch
nicht irgendwie ja hier und immer voll
together thema für die kletter show ich
weiß dass jetzt erst mal auf mich an
dass wir das hier zu erwähnen aber es
soll halt wirklich auch bei dem namen
bleiben
und natürlich sind wir sehr stolz
tochter und alleine darf deswegen
verlassen projekt von luca um ihr
zusammen ist persönlicher sein von congo
after rein darf mich duzen echten beim
nicht eine frage an sie und zwar darf
ich sie nutzen aber nein was rede ich
hier auf jeden fall sollten sie noch
helfen
eigentlich ein abtragen jetzt habe ich
in diesem moment bin ich fertig sie
können abbauen und verschwinden ich
überlege nur aus was für ein stoff ich
meine häuser hier mache erstmal bräuchen
ofenfertig kokain kokain des rap stars
sind eigentlich voll die gute idee wo er
ist immer so gute ideen
also ich hätte jetzt auch noch ein thema
mit uns fallen ja selber themen ein aber
wir wollen sie kommen jetzt aber ich
wollte jetzt vorbei sein kann ich
nämlich noch erwähnen was ich sagen
wollte
naja moment ich möchte ganz kurz an
einem fall beim let's play auch immer
themen über die man reden kann aber wir
wollen uns da zurückhaltend und wollen
eigentlich eure themen benutzen nächste
folge die paralympics danke an focus
online die uns diesen dieses thema
gesendet haben blabla aber wir kamen zum
beispiel gerade wieder in den sinn ich
hab letztens eine reportage gesehen oder
haschisch versus alkohol also welches
alkohol alkoholische getränke und
haschisch hat gewonnen mit vier punkten
vorsprung von 8 zu 4 oder so einen
punkten in wasser das gewonnen ist
geiler nein in den kategorien
abhängigkeit und alles so zwei von
pfiffen kann man nicht abhängig wären
aber solche themen möchten wir gar nicht
besprechen wir wollen dass alles auf dem
intellektuell hochwertigen niveau
natürlich halten das auch eine gewagte
these
das war jetzt auch ironisch gemeint und
ja jetzt folgt auch schon einmal vorbei
aber nein wir wollen gar nicht so dem
aufnahmen mit ende hiergegen
entgegensehen
ich wollte nur ganze abschließend zu
dieser folge sagen dass ihr uns dann
halt wieder in die kommentare
das thema schreiben sollte findet ihr
solche themen wie die paralympics so ein
thema auch gut oder wirklich nur themen
die uns zu sehen aber es wäre ein paar
ballwechseln voll behindert
der wahlzettel club verwehrt waren
schenkelklopfer ach so schenke erhält
übrigens werden immer noch keine schafe
das ist extrem blöd
die nächste die platz acht beginn sind
wir sehen uns in der nächsten folge und
damit geht es dann auch direkt weiter
die nacht beginnt
was hast du hast ja irgendwas gemacht
oder hier nur rumgelaufen bei mir ich
hab nur um gelaufen
ich habe er hat kontakte er hat er hat
nur um gelaufen
das ist jetzt umkehrung vom ersten
together was wir gemacht haben also
nicht die zuschauer sondern mal wer da
wo ich immer so wenig gemacht habe ich
empfehle dir ich mache mir gerade hier
ich muss ich muss mich ja neben dich
bauen und deswegen mache ich mir gar den
keller zu du hier war eine riesige hürde
hab ich grad alles zugemacht bin ganz am
rad kann hier und du doch doch ich
fragte gemacht und du so ich erlebte
gleich was habe ich getan
das ist hier nichts
es geht gleich los da bin ich aber da
auf jeden fall meine tür kommt ja zu dir
so niedrig stunde